my friend from pro football talk he
kicks off um our day every single day
here on nbc puts nbc sports on peacock
with pro football talk live mike florio
back here in the rich island show how
are you mike i'm doing great rich how
are you today i'm fine so um the tampa
bay times story about antonio brown's
vaccination card whether it's real
whether it's not how can the league
possibly
investigate this they say they're
looking into it but what's what is that
what would that even mean well first
i'll say this if they had created odds
at points bet of the players most likely
to be accused of having a fake
vaccination card it would have been
minus 250
for antonio brown wouldn't it i mean
isn't he just the one that you would
think of first
there and there are others who i won't
name since they have yet to be accused
of having a fake vaccination card but
antonio would have been near the top so
he came through go cash your ticket and
in in all seriousness the league has the
power
to
resolve this pretty quickly depending
upon the quality of the documentation
that the buccaneers retained
the quality of the documentation that
antonio brown retained in rick stroud's
excellent story alex guerrero of all
people is the one who was at brown's
house a couple of days before training
camp opened and took a picture of
brown's vaccination card and delivered
it to the team's head trainer now the
league doesn't get the vaccination cards
my understanding is the team isn't
required to keep the vaccination cards
but rich from the information on a
vaccination card
it is very simple for an employer to
verify
the accuracy because it provides the
name of the person who got the shot
where the shot was administered
the lot number of the vaccine
depending upon whether it's pfizer
moderna johnson and johnson
and the date
and if any information is false
when you try to confirm
the accuracy of what's on that
vaccination card it's all going to be
exposed quickly they're not going to
have a record that that individual had a
shot that day at that place from that
lot number of that vaccine period
and
there have been enough
rumors and rumblings of fake vaccination
cards floating around that
i think it's incumbent on some of these
teams to maybe
do it themselves and now the league can
do it and now the question is how far
down the rabbit hole are they going to
go are they going to check antonio
brown's are they going to do a more
comprehensive audit of all teams the
buccaneers and all other teams
and find out how many other
fake vaccination cards have or haven't
been used that's really the question
they can go a long way here how broadly
do they brush or do they just focus on
antonio brown but they should be able to
get to the bottom of this if they want
to yeah i i guess so i i mean just
the league wide you know uh check of
everybody's vaccination card is like
come on you know it
i i i i
i don't know what else to say other than
the fact like
um what a damn shame that would have to
be if they get to that point in time and
what a what a what a monumental sort of
um logistical problem that might
actually look at but maybe they throw it
on the teams i i don't know but what
what would the what would the punishment
be for this well but this way rich
either you care you don't care about
people who are showing up and pretending
to be vaccinated when they really aren't
i mean that's the the worst violation of
the protocols that you could imagine
they create two buckets one for the
people who are vaccinated which are much
more lenient and favorable and then
the protocols that apply to those who
choose not to be vaccinated if you are
pretending
both internally and externally for aaron
rodgers it was just externally
for someone with a fake vaccination card
it's externally internally for all
purposes if you're pretending to be
vaccinated and these cards you i mean
i could print one out i mean i i can't
imagine it would be that hard to create
a forged vaccination card because a lot
of the information is hand written on
these things
so yeah i think that they should have
been more vigilant about it from the
get-go and now the question is how
vigilant are they going to be after the
fact but it's a violation of the
personal conduct policy if it's proven
and that's particularly bad news for
antonio brown because he already has a
suspension on his fairly recent past
eight games last year for a conduct
policy violation arising from multiple
off-season issues he'd be treated as a
repeat offender and he'd be subject to
enhanced penalties now i have no idea
what the baseline penalty would be under
the conduct policy because this is
unprecedented but whatever it is it
would likely be even greater for him
because of his past issues so he's
looking at a problem here if the league
is able to show that he did have a fake
vaccination card
mike florio here
on the rich eisen show um so the rest of
week 11 let's let's hit it right here uh
is kyla murray going to go do you think
what are you what are you hearing about
on the injury front uh with one of the
star role
players of a team that's uh that's lost
a couple out of their last three well on
football night in america we explained
that he was making progress if the
progress continues he'll play one of the
big factors here is that they have their
buy
after this sunday's game against a very
desperate seahawks team so do you give
him that extra week and a lot of it
depends upon just how comfortable the
cardinals ultimately are putting him out
there and you can say well you know if
he gets banged up a little bit if he has
a little aggravation he's got two weeks
until his next game so
i think that that
given that
there isn't a ton of margin for error if
you are trying to win the division with
the rams and they they got a little bit
of a of a bonus on monday night when the
rams lost you don't want to extend one
loss to two in a row going into your bye
week and i suspect he's going to play
and uh you know maybe they'll be
watching him closely if there's any sign
of any aggravation then they'll get him
out of the game but i suspect he's going
to play what about this sunday night uh
football night in america with big ben
do you think he's going to hop on a
flight uh in the next 24 hours and play
48 hours from now i don't know of any
player who has been able to come back
faster than 10 days when vaccinated and
testing positive for covet one of the
inducements to get guys to choose to be
vaccinated is hey if you're vaccinating
test positive you get to come back if
you generate a negative test within or
at a minimum of 24 hours apart but it
just doesn't happen it doesn't happen
within 10 days it doesn't happen within
five days we've seen it with seven days
etc it'll be eight days for ben
roethlisberger i'd be surprised if he
ends up being able to play but
ultimately it's not like any other
injury that you can you know
tape your ankle or whatever you either
test negative or you don't twice at
least 24 hours apart and yeah the fact
that it's in la is another complication
if they were playing at home this
weekend he could i guess in theory test
negative you know mid afternoon on
sunday and be good to go
so um
that's sunday night football um and then
the cleveland browns they took nick
chubb
um and felton off of the coveted list
today so it looks like he's going right
for cleveland this weekend yeah you know
the one thing to remember though and
chandler jones went through this he
missed a game
because he was positive for covet and
then once he came back he missed another
game because he'd lost like 15 pounds
while fighting cove and so when you plug
a guy right back in we had this question
last week with aaron rodgers your
brother got right back in
is he going to be ready to go
in 48 hours when he hasn't been around
when he hasn't been practicing
and when he possibly has had
some negative effects of that positive
cova diagnosis so it's wait and see
but you know he's back which is the
biggest hurdle to clear if you want to
get on the field but it wouldn't be
unprecedented if for some reason he's
limited or just flat out unable to go i
think uh mike of mike florio of pro
football talk here on the rich eisen
show i want to get this right um i
should have had it open but your your uh
headline of your coverage of the um
the nfl walt anderson sending out um a
video of what players can and cannot do
to avoid
being in the zone of making a referee
call you for a taunt or a posture it was
perfect like you know
uh players not being able to contain
themselves emotionally that the nfl is
backing the play of
players needing to contain themselves
emotionally their basic human emotions
like why is the nfl
just going further and further to a
point where even on dan's show uh which
is between yours and mine every day on
peacock sean payton who's on the
competition committee says they're
overfishing that's that they that what's
happening on the field isn't even
remotely close to what they were talking
about in the meetings why why are they
doing that well i i don't get it rich
mckay the chair of the competition
committee when they announced the latest
point of emphasis on taunting they did
this in 2014 and they did it again this
year he made it clear that they want to
get rid of the in-your-face
drawing between players who then
may have a vendetta that gets acted out
upon later either through a fight or
through an effort to go take a shot of
the guy a legal shot but a gratuitous
unnecessary shot of the guy during a
play they don't want to have a guy
keeping score you know i'll get this guy
that that's what they're trying to avoid
at some point it morphed into this
broader concern about
posturing toward an entire sideline and
that was the cassius marsh thing and see
when you're not wired or willing to
admit a mistake and you double down
number one you create a bunch of
criticism and frankly i think the league
liked the focus on the cassius marsh
thing because it took away emphasis from
the ridiculous low block call that took
a touchdown off the board that same
night and i've been told that that's
true that they they love that
distraction because that was an
indefensible call by tony corenti
but now you've got this posturing
standard
and i've already got coaches sending me
examples of similar conduct that isn't
flagged see how are you gonna call this
consistently that that's the separate
issue whether we agree with the rule or
not and most people don't at least
especially how it's being
applied in some cases now if you're not
applying it and for enforcing it
consistently
that's a problem because then it all
seems too subjective it seems random it
seems like you know we just pulled the
flag out when we feel like it and the
nfl needs to be concerned about that
because you don't want to give people
any plausible basis to think that the
fix is in and i firmly believe the fix
is never in
but
i also would prefer that people don't
have a plausible
argument that the fix could be in i
don't like that and they need to be as
vigilant as they can if they're going to
enforce this rule they've got to enforce
it all the time and they've got to
enforce it consistently or it is going
to create these situations where people
are like something fishy is going on
here so what but but but who's the one
pushing it now
now like i understand before it was you
know john mara representing ownership
and rich mckay representing upper
management and
tomlin and payton whoever else is on
that committee representing coaches and
there was a coaching committee that
actually forwarded to the competition
committee i understand how it was born
but why are we seeing it now like this
like who's sitting there saying let's
back karenti and i understand you say
they're covering up for other calls and
that's just in the here and now i mean
that's just between weeks nine and ten
right just to get to get to to game
action in week ten to change the
narrative or what have you but why send
out this
this this this video from walt anderson
to everybody basically again putting it
on the lap of the players we're already
telling a player that you know hit the
proper strike zone during the game even
though the person that you're hitting
changes his body position that might
make you hit a part of the strike zone
you're intending to hit we're already
laying that on the players why are we
now saying don't put us in the position
of making the stupid call of having
somebody wordlessly posture at a
sideline as a as a uh as a taunt why
who's doing that well i think
here's the reality there's a combination
of personalities and mindsets in the
league office and the people who
actually have the ear of the
commissioner and
once you start down the path of
defending
bad calls whenever and however you can
minimal transparency
long gone are the days of the dean
blandinos and the mike pereiras who
could appear on nfl network's total
access and explain and admit
when maybe
a referee went a little bit too far you
never get that now you get
you get
if anything and we've seen him each of
the past two weeks perry fuel who works
with the officiating function now
we'll do an 80-second video where he
just says here's the call and here's why
it was made and here's why it was right
and you move on to the next one there's
no acknowledgement of mistake and i
think this thing
that
went out this past week with the memo in
the video is a product of
this effort to
defend the currently call
back up this standard and put it all on
the players this is it hey we don't want
to have to do this we don't want to have
to turn this car around you know this is
going to hurt us more than it hurts you
any other cliche you want to throw in
there it's your fault if we do it it's
not our fault for being overly officious
you're on notice of what you need to
avoid and you know the reality is
you're going to see
you know the coaches who understand the
linear connection between
15 yards of field position and winning
and losing games like bill belichick
making sure his guys understand that you
may not like it but you got to
understand it you got to control
yourself just like you have to control
yourself when it comes to holding or any
other foul that could be called against
a player same thing as just don't reach
for the pylon some teams do it uh one
you know some teams don't and it's i
guess
the latest example of that because you
don't want to run a follow the rule book
i i just i just don't like again it's
like taking the targeting rule and
applying it to celebrations
and uh that's when you're gonna get uh
as you've pointed out some inconsistency
in actually calling it and i i i don't
understand why they want to go in that
direction i don't understand it was
would have been very simple as saying we
of course we don't want somebody
wordlessly staring at a sideline um on
monday night football with three minutes
to go in a game costing anything like
that of course that's not what we want
we just we want everybody just to tone
it down
what's wrong with you live the day after
that game how do we know that the guy's
mom wasn't in the front row
and he was saying you know look ma look
at me ma look what i did i'm you know
yeah how we we are inferring meaning
from someone's bodily motions and it's
one thing if you've got two guys who are
right in each other's faces then you
know it when you see it right i think
that's what makes it a little more
difficult we're applying the potter
stewart standard in situations where
it it it you you're you're making some
assumptions that may not be warranted
and how do you know for sure that that's
what that guy was doing and how is that
going to set the stage for further
issues if the whole thing is we want to
nip in the bud any possibility of either
extracurricular stuff or permissible
from snap to whistle hits that are born
of this desire to get back at a guy if
that's the goal
why are you saying you can't posture an
entire sideline i mean that that
so logically the whole thing continues
to collapse but they're not going to
admit they were wrong so they're going
to as we said they're going to make sure
the players know what the rule is and
expect the coaches to coach it that way
and if you get flagged it's your own
fault it's not our fault last thing for
you i got a couple minutes but i've been
curious to get your thoughts what about
gruden's lawsuit where does that go what
do you think happens here what's the
goal to get discovery and get more
emails out that people don't want to see
i mean
what is the goal well the argument is
very simple if the emails hadn't become
public he probably wouldn't have been
fired by mark davis now i don't know
that mark davis is going to get on
witness stand and say if this had all
been done privately and they had sent
them to me i wouldn't have fired him i
would have said all this happened before
he came to work for me i want to keep
john gruden as my coach once the emails
are out it becomes untenable and his
argument is a very strong
statement an allegation that the nfl
denies but the argument is
you specifically targeted me you tried
to take me out and you took me out by
releasing these emails so
you know there will be some
initial preliminary procedural issues i
think the nfl will try to find a way to
argue that the entire dispute should be
resolved in arbitration because that's
the first thing that any major business
tries to do when it's sued it wants to
get it out of the court system and get
it into
a much more discreet and much more
favorable to business interest type of a
setting and then you know we'll fight
that for six months ten months who knows
how long but yeah if this thing survives
in court
you'll have people who are questioned
under oath you'll have documents that
are produced and certain things will be
subject to a protective order but
certain other things will be attached to
exhibits to documents that are filed
that's how we've gotten a glimpse of
some of the things in the st louis
relocation litigation so this is going
to hang around for a while the nfl is
going to fight it
but at some point at some point this is
what they should have done after the st
louis litigation ended up not making its
way to arbitration at some point you got
to recognize when the time is right to
write a check because the damage that
ultimately can be done is a lot worse
than whatever amount you pay to make
this thing go away and they need to be
ready to do it at the right time with
gruden or who knows what's ultimately
going to come out mike thanks for the
time appreciate it have a great uh
weekend and a great thanksgiving and
let's chat after that all right thanks
rich right back at you that's mike
florio right there on the rich eisen
show hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here